by way of transition as Denis strelkov
he comes up to the podium I'll say I
think that the presentations and that we
heard from lolly and Jonathan and also
the question about the Georgia Tech case
moved us very firmly from from past to
present challenges but what is the
future of the library one answer to that
that has been suggested is open access
and so Denise now will share with us her
thoughts on what copyright challenges
that future might bring I'm so little
let me try to get this where you'll be
able to hear me it's a pleasure to be
here I was honored to be invited to
speak at this event I've always looked
on these three folks who I'm on the
panel with here as big fish and I'm a
little guppy and here i am with these
folks and i was so intimidated I
couldn't even at first think about doing
this but here I am we're okay move a
little farther okay so I'm here today to
talk to you about the ethics of open
access to research and i want to
emphasize right there number one
research i'm not talking about novels
and poetry i'm talking about basically
the journal literature i'm going to
introduce a few concepts from a book if
you have not read it i strongly
encourage you to read korean MacGarry's
book who owns academic work she starts
by describing what she calls epistemic
regime which talks about two worlds of
knowledge on the one side we have the
Academy which sort of she calls it
police's ivory prefer the word champions
champions the world of what is called
cognitive property knowledge that cannot
be owned ideas and facts that operate in
which he calls a monopoly of confidence
or the gift economy on the other side we
have intellectual property law which
champions the knowledge that can be
owned knowledge captured in artifacts
that operate under the monopoly of
copyright in a market economy she
describes authorship
as a boundary object a boundary object
is a vehicle to deploy norms of one
economy in another the way this happens
in terms again of research is faculty
authors in the Academy create new
knowledge new cognitive property these
facts and ideas they operate in an ethic
of sharing and moral obligations meaning
the value faculty to see in their work
is recognition and reward that they get
from it which may include grant funding
down the line but it's not direct income
from the sale of those facts and ideas
the difficulty comes because of our
automatic copyright is when they go to
share these facts and ideas that cannot
be owned they have to express them as
soon as they express them and they are
in fixed form they now enter the world
of the market economy of intellectual
property law where they operate under
another ethic the ethic of property in
economic rights where the value is the
potential for economic gain but in this
case not the academic economic gain of
the researcher faculty author but the
publisher which brings us to the point
that faculty operate under a hybrid
ethic they want what is called academic
exception meaning their work is not a
work for hire by the institution they
own their work okay their cognitive
property and hence they want to own the
intellectual property that comes when
they express that they this idea derives
from their ethic of both honor and
propriety in the gift economy and
academic freedom and control in the
market economy we've heard from Harvard
and MIT faculty that don't fall into
this next bullet I have here but this is
the Carnegie Mellon faculty model and I
believe it operates in other places as
well our faculty resist anything that
challenges their sense of honor
propriety autonomy and control they do
not want help managing their copyrights
they do not want policies requiring them
to license rates to the institution or
requiring them to retain rights they
know what they want to do and what do
they do they turn around and they give
their copyright to the publisher
they exercise their economy the question
is do they lose control in some ways
they find out later hey I have to buy
back my own figures and tables to use
them in other ways well we'll get to the
control issue in a little bit but what
it turns out to be is when push comes to
shove to academic faculty it seems to be
that recognition and reward the gift
economy is more important than
intellectual property and copyright
which brings us to make Sherry's notion
of a border dispute in a border dispute
things on both sides of the line starts
to have have a skirmish and this
skirmish creates and addresses moral
communities i postulate that open access
is a border skirmish of monumental
proportions it is the gift economy
encroaching on market space it is
diversity of confrontational and
competitive it's a high priority for
academia and certainly has aroused the
ire of the Death Star publishers now
we're going to take a little shift here
and I want to look at some data many of
you if you've heard me talk there is
always data in my talks I am data driven
this is a study that I conducted with
help of some colleagues at Carnegie
Mellon in 2007 2008 at the time we did
not have an institutional repository but
we wanted to support our faculty and
self archiving on personal and
departmental web sites we wanted some
bench line data so we looked at all of
the citations that every single faculty
at the institution had on their websites
coded everything and this is the journal
data what we discovered was that of the
over 14,000 articles available or cited
on our faculty websites thirty two
percent of them had links to open access
copies and thirty-four percent of our
faculty had self archive one or more
journals we then wanted to know if what
they were doing was legal and because
the way the faculty had self archived
things we could not tell if an author
version was a print print or post print
we could not tell if they had complied
with embargo periods so we looked at
what we called alignment and we focused
on did the publisher allow self
archiving on websites and if so what did
they
allow require or permit in terms of the
publisher PDF and what we discovered was
that close to forty percent of the
things over all that were self archived
were not aligned with policy and the
percentage was much higher in some of
the colleges so then we look to drove a
little bit deeper to figure out how was
it that these things were not aligned
and the biggest problem was the self
archiving of the publisher PDF when the
publisher did not allow this and I would
say this is because that is the best
gift it is the preserved record it is
the work that can be cited a recent
study showed that something like eighty
to ninety percent of the faculty want to
self archive the publisher PDF so now I
get back to the more theoretical ethical
discussion here who cares all right the
public certainly has not been upset if
faculty are breaching publisher policy
or copyright law publishers care because
of the impact on the market but their
response has not been punitive it's been
more political faculty may or may not
know that they are infringing copyright
and breaching publisher policy but if
they do know they clearly assume that no
harm is going to come to them or their
institution the Academy as a whole seems
to care you know there's efforts to get
you know faculty retain rights to
license race to the institution but they
haven't really come down on the faculty
for this it's not seen as a serious
breach of you know faculty standards of
contact it certainly is punt ducked it
certainly isn't moral turpitude and if
the faculty infringe copyright the
institution is not responsible but what
happens when you come to an
institutional repository that's operated
or mediated by the library we now have
an institutional repository if the
library mediates infringing works the
institution could be responsible for
this under the law so it's a very
different situation so we wrestled with
this whole notion of do we have to fully
comply with law and policy or is
alignment good enough if we go for full
compliance we will certainly have poor
return on our investment we will
discourage the faculty that will annoy
the provost we will be compromising our
own values and strategic goals
compliance full compliance may not even
be
simple technologically with the software
we've licensed alignment on the other
hand could help us achieve some of our
goals reduce our risks and be true to
who we are and I have listed here some
of the core values of librarianship so
now comes the question and I think we
all probably know that law and ethics
are not synonyms is copyright
infringement illegal yes it certainly is
is copyright infringement unethical yes
but there seems to be a difference
between infringing your own work and by
that mean your own cognitive property
that was produced and given as a gift
from infringing someone else's work or
work that was produced for money I see a
big difference between what our faculty
are doing and what software pirates and
and some of these folks are doing
according to McSherry a gift has to be
permitted to circulate as soon as it's
withdrawn from circulation and
transformed into capital it loses the
status as a gift and remember our
faculty continue to operate even though
their work is now on a market economy
still they operate from a gift economy
to them it is still a gift research is a
horse of a different color these are
probably famous quotes I don't need to
you know tell you about it but copyright
monopoly is not the reason our faculty
produce work and Georgia Harper or
copyright attorney said it is symposium
in Texas a month or two ago that we need
to demonstrate and as we've been doing
in the open access movement we just need
to keep pushing what she calls and
borrowed the term I think from James
Boyle the existence proof that copyright
is inappropriate and unnecessary for
research so what is ethics about ethics
is about what's best for all concerned
and sort of tools of ethical analysis
calls us to look look at intentions
foreseen consequences and if down the
line we have some unforeseen but harmful
consequences we need to adjust our
course for intentions to be ethical they
have to be both self and other regarding
you don't just think about yourself you
look you look at the bigger picture how
is what you're intending to do going to
affect not just you but other people in
terms of forcing consequences ethically
speaking that
sists tell us that we may accept harmful
unform phul foreseen consequences if the
cost doesn't exceed the benefit and if
we take steps to try to avoid or
minimize the harmful consequences above
all we dare not sacrifice a greater good
for a lesser good and of course there's
some harmful consequences that we did
not foresee we must adjust course so
returning back to the open access border
skirmish I would argue that the
intentions and originally foreseen
consequences of both researchers and
publishers were both self and other
regarding what surfaced over time and
originally was an unforeseen harmful
consequence but now we see it which is
why I have unbreak itted there from the
researchers perspective the harmful
unforeseen consequences with was that
the publishers would start to hold their
work hostage and for a ransom that
increasingly if you can pay from the
publishers perspective they harmful
unforeseen consequences was all of a
sudden these authors we're going to
start to exercise their original
copyright ownership or just start
rescuing hostages without negotiating at
all so what do we do here we are at
carnegie mellon we have decided and when
we look at institutional repositories
and the amount of content in these
repositories repositories that is
breaching copyright law and publish your
policy we don't think we're alone but at
least we've made the informed decision
or willing to talk about it we think
alignment is best we are not ignoring
publisher policy that we think full
compliance is is virtually impossible
and interferes with our our priorities
and our principles and our values and
who we are so we are settling for
alignment it maps to what we think we
are about it attempts to minimize
harmful for seeing consequences it
increases the return on investment in
research not just the institutional
repository but also the institutional
repository it sends a signal to the
Death Star and it enables us to assist
in in the hostage rescue that our
faculty want so I raise this as a
question
ken librarianship operationalized in an
institutional repository operate as a
boundary object which is a vehicle to
deploy the norms and values of the gift
economy in the research marketplace so
what I'm calling for is that libraries
exercise and foster tempered civil
disobedience and moral courage according
to Henry David Thoreau in a democracy
when conscience and law clash we are
morally justified if not duty bound to
follow our conscience not wait for the
law to change remind you again of
Georgia Harper's Hawk Congress moves
glacially slowly we cannot wait
rushworth kidder talks about moral
courage as operating to preserve what he
has empirically researched as
cross-cultural core values that when we
are opposed and when success entails
risk we act to preserve the values of
honesty fairness respect responsibility
and compassion and I hold these up as
examples from the Death Star but I have
encountered personally in participating
in round tables on the section 108
issues roundtables on orphan works
lobbying for open access this is the
kind of behavior I'll use that word that
calls me to step up and say we need to
defend honesty fairness respect
responsibility and compassion thank you
very much thank you so much to me
well welcome now our final speaker Kenny
Cruz and I think that Denise's
presentation you know drove home the
point that as libraries increasingly act
as digital archives we encounter new
copyright challenges and the death
achill as legal dimensions of that are
not always aligned and taking that idea
one step further I think Kenny will
speak to us about what he sees as the
fractured future or should we say
futures maybe take it away okay all
right there we go enough public
performance good good welcome and thank
thank you leah thanks to everybody
thanks here every two to all of you to
everybody at yale law school for making
this event possible thank you for your
patience we're having a wonderful day
but I know I know it's I know it's
sometimes engrossing as well as enduring
to be here for a long day so thank you
all very much my my presentation really
is that reckless look at the future what
I think the future might bring and one
of the benefits of doing that is that
it's going to take a long time for you
to prove me wrong so I can just just go
out there and say something about what I
think of the future of copyright and and
well you know we talk about copyright as
if it's a unified whole really my key
word is fracturing it's fragmentation
it's splintering it's all sorts of
things like that this is the direction
where I think we're going with copyright
and and there are so many possibilities
for directions that we might head we
might very well just stick with the
status quo and and frankly that's
impossible we are already putting a lot
of strain on the status of copyright in
the way copyright works today I don't
think that we can stay with where we are
some people have talked rather rather
fleetingly about repeal well that's not
likely i think saying not likely is in
under
so we're not going to see a repeal of
the law any time that I can imagine what
about stronger rights and ramping up
rights with respect to copyrighted works
and copyright owners well honestly
that's the direction we've been going
for decades stepping up rights granting
more rights granting rights for a longer
period of years that is exactly what we
have been doing and I think that's one
of the reasons why we're running into a
collision why it is that we're testing
the viability of copyright today so that
current direction is really I don't
believe a sustainable direction then we
throw in this word about balancing or
rebalancing and I'm just going to toss
it right back at you and say that's a
loser e in fact I've tried really hard
to stop using the word balance in my
discussion of copyright it's been part
of the cliche for a hundred years at
least since nineteen oh nine right lolly
and and and and I've just decided it's
time to stop it's time to take a
position and not really talk about
balancing this isn't about balancing
this is about trying to do good things
and so in another way that we could
describe the direction that we're going
is this word international and I think
the answer there's absolutely i think
we're finding that that's what is really
an inevitable part of the direction that
we're heading with copyright and again
we could say this too we've been heading
that direction for at least a hundred
years but i think it's becoming an even
more powerful more important force on
the shape of domestic copyright law but
that might be a whole other subject
let's let's get back and talk about a
little bit about where we might be
heading in broad general terms with
copyright and and let me start with that
social interface because ultimately the
laws about people law makes no sense at
all except the way it relates to people
and the way people relate to it so let's
look at some example
of the way we've had a kind of an
awkward relationship with copyright
awkward as a species human beings and
our relationship to this thing well
we've had a huge dose of selective
ignorance the thing I call the Napster
phenomenon I'm going to upload it and
download it because I can and because I
want to it's it's a it's a kind of
selective ignorance about copyright in
the way it works we've had a lot of that
we have a tremendous amount of tolerated
behavior but we have a real tolerance
divide some things that are tolerable to
me are not tolerable to you and yet we
have had huge strata of tolerated
behavior we've had accepted or
acceptable behavior we can clock that
way back lolly talked about the
gentleman's agreement from 1935 that was
kind of a statement of nevermind the law
we're willing to accept this kind of
copying because we can't figure out the
law or whatever whatever other reason
and then we've had a sphere of
unreachable behavior certain things that
are just beyond the grasp of whoever
might want to control it but as we move
into this thing called library 2.0 or
whatever label we call it in the future
we really have this sort of helpless or
hapless abandonment the the user
generated material kind of falls in that
category try applying a conventional
legal analysis to the exchange on the
internet to wikis and their development
to even the good old-fashioned student
projects spray-painted on the wall by
multiple students the traditional legal
analysis falls apart and yet the law
applies and yet we can't figure out the
law or at least make it function in a
practical manner so we have an awkward
social relationship with copyright
and then we have a really awkward just
legal functioning that even when we see
something or somebody sees something
that they think they can reach they
think they can control they think they
would like to stop there's really a
failure of enforceability in so many
many many situations the cost of
enforcement is prohibitive the burden of
engaging the legal system is simply not
worth it in most kinds of situations and
then try getting criminal prosecution
notice you don't see a lot of that
relative to the amount of copyright
activity that's occurring that criminal
prosecution is rare because the system
just can't adapt to the burden of
engaging these these legal possibilities
and then even if you can get somebody in
the net the remedies in many many cases
simply are not very effective or
ultimately not worth the while and so we
have private responses stepping out of
the system of laws and statutes and
court cases we have private responses
we've seen this growth of Licensing in
so many ways in so many directions we've
seen the growth of collective licensing
the mentions during the day of things
like the copyright Clearance Center
ASCAP BMI these collective license
systems stepping in we have
technological protection measures that
are designed to control who and how a
work may be used and and so try to
assert a sort of quasi legal framework
where the law doesn't necessarily work
well and then there's good old
litigation and two very notable class
actions that we're struggling with today
one going before the Supreme Court this
year about the rights associated with
articles by independent contractors
submitted to newspapers as well as of
course the google books more about that
one coming up we are seeing I think
through a couple of other prize
initiatives a sort of structural
reworking of the environment of
copyright law one of those is creative
commons another one the open access
movement that we just heard about and a
third that i want to focus on is that
google book settlement think of these as
somebody whoever that might be stepping
in and saying here's a chance to rework
the rules for better or for worse you
decide for example Creative Commons is
really a tempering of copyright it's
saying I own the copyright but I hereby
grant to the public these rights of use
or I own the copyright and guess what
the copyright doesn't do what I want so
I want something else I want my name on
the work I want attribution you want
your name on the work you better say so
because the law doesn't protect that and
so creative commons is a way of saying I
don't want everything the law gives me I
want something different and let me work
it out privately it's a private
restructuring of opting in and opting
out open access it's again an assertion
of the copyright in order to limit the
copyright I own the copyright I hereby
grant open access I hereby grant access
to the public alike Creative Commons
it's a clarification of Rights it's a
reallocation as well of the economics of
the copyright system and third on my
list is google books settlement back to
that word fragmentation it's a
fragmenting of books so now we're seeing
a settlement that's going to define the
terms on which we as researchers and
readers will be able to access books but
for starters it's only some books
complicate complicated definition about
registered unregistered
stick foreign but a cutoff date in
January of 2009 it's a lot of books but
it's not all books and it's a
dismantling of those books themselves so
that ultimately it's a delivery of
portion it's a sale of just some things
some rights the downloads there's an
excision of images from the works I also
predict throw this on my list of
predictions a lot of very frustrated
researchers and users when they get
their hands on this database and they
realize that it's delivering these
decimated things called books and so
also splitting it up it's a
non-exclusive the books that are in this
database and so many of them are going
to spring up in alternative sources and
so we're going to find them in google
but we're going to find them over here
and we're going to find them over there
and now we're going to start shopping
for the one that delivers on the most
helpful and the friendliest terms and
it's only about books it's not about
journals images music art it's not about
any of those other things so whatever
the rules are it's only about some types
of works and it's only about some
elements of those works and so the big
picture back to fragmentation I think
what we're talking about as we see these
different terms on which works are going
to become available to us we're going to
see a fragmentation of authors some
authors are going to be asserting rights
some not some transferring rights some
not some doing portions of Rights some
doing all rights fragmentation of works
themselves some with restrictions some
not some wholesome partial fragmentation
of readers those who are connected in
those who aren't those who are satisfied
with searching of elements of a work
versus those who need the whole work
fragmentation of publishers delivering
portions different formats different
media and then the fragmentation of
libraries libraries had
have a wealth of material and access to
a wealth of material but that material
is restricted by licensing with diverse
terms and here's another keyword that we
could run through the last few slides
blurring we're going to take all of
these parties publishers libraries
authors the works themselves the readers
and we're going to break them up and
we're going to rearrange the pieces
because readers are going to be like
authors authors are going to be like
publishers publishers are going to be
like libraries libraries are going to be
like publishers we're going to take on
characteristics of each other and in
that we're going to be struggling with
an age-old 1909 style copyright law and
figuring out what it means in that kind
of context so pick your metaphor an
avalanche of metaphors pick your
metaphor we're going to have this
exploding universe of works more and
more works made more and more available
more activity libraries are going to be
engaged in more and more complex
activity with respect to their work and
management of this process we're going
to see diversity of works and terms and
licensing we're going to see different
players playing the role of being a
gatekeeper we're going to see libraries
as appeasers as users express their
frustration and their anger over the
different kinds of works that are
available on different terms and then
we're going to find ourselves saying I'm
sorry I'm sorry I know you need it and I
know your friend got it from someplace
else but I've only got it in this
database and this database delivers only
in these pieces and that's all I've got
here we're going to become the
apologists in many ways for the chaos
and the fragmentation that lies ahead is
that optimistic thank you very much
so now I'll invite our audience members
up to the microphones and just say thank
you again to Denise and to Kenny very
rich and complex a picture of what the
future copyright challenges might look
like i do want to take a couple
questions together if possible and also
I unfortunately don't have a twitter
machine in front of me at the moment and
i know that there's been a great
dialogue and talkback happening there so
if anybody wants to come up to the
microphone and share somebody else's
question that they saw on twitter that
would also be great so please Denise I
was wondering if you could define a
little more specifically what you mean
by alignment and how its distinct from
compliance and if it isn't compliance
what good does it do for you if an angry
rights holder comes calling ok great
question i'm gonna i'm going to invite
the second question 2 and then we'll
we'll we'll have a chance to share our
answers to both of them also to Denise
over time I you know known you for years
and years you've worked with a million
books project all sorts of things starts
getting large things online you've
seemed to have changed your position
somewhat can you describe a little bit
of sort of how you found yourself on
this trajectory Denise both those
questions are for you once you take them
together okay so the first gentleman's
question IC compliance as following all
of the if I may use the word Picayune
details that the publishers have put in
their policies when you put up to the
post print if it's allowed or the
preprint you have to have this
descriptive text when the thing gets
published you have to take it down and
replace with this descriptive text you
know when the thing depending on like if
it's i triple e then you must publish or
post the publisher PDF you must have a
link to the publisher PDF if they don't
allow the P so I when I say compliance
I'm talking about one hundred percent
going along with
all of those Picayune details that's how
IC compliance alignment I see as an
informed choice based on what risk
you're willing to take about what you
think are the key important ingredients
for example if the publisher does not
allow self archiving I think that's
important and you don't muck with that
one but if they say yes you can self
archive this on your website or in an
institutional repository and and I will
speak for myself individually here
because the libraries are still working
out their understanding of alignment but
I'm willing to ignore this must be the
text when you put up the preprint and
then when the thing is published you
have to change that text so it's to me
alignment is making an informed choice
about which of those items that are in
the policy you you are willing to do and
which you are willing to dispense with
and take the risk for dispensing with
those does that explain to the person
what I meant and how do I think that
covers us I think it covers us because
it respects first the publishers a
choice whether or not to allow open
access so that's the primary thing and
we're respecting that I think it also
shows respect because we are looking at
all of their requirements and making an
informed choice to lower our risks and
minimize harm to ourselves and to others
so I think in that way it kind of
protects us that we have thought about
this we have weighed the pros and cons
we have made an informed choice and we
are going to stand behind what we've
done if we're given takedown notices
will take it down does that help now to
get to brusters question and yes I
thought we would have this conversation
privately but we'll dance it out here
yes I have worked with Brewster for many
years and he knew me when I was first
learning about copyright and I was
always going but but but the law says
but what the law says and and Brewster
and the big fish would be saying did he
see how we know what the law says but
you know we're taking this path and I'd
be like but the law says
because I just part of me wanted to make
sure it was an informed choice that they
hadn't and forgive me because I was just
new to this and they probably knew all
of the copyright law but I was all
excited about what I was learning and I
wanted to make sure they weren't
overlooking a point because I wanted
them to make informed choices and not
caught by surprise later so that it
wouldn't come back on me because I was
supposed to be the one tracking this
that they didn't come back and say you
didn't tell us so that was a piece of it
and another piece was that I myself had
not personally worked through the ethics
of it I was scared I was conservative
and I have spent some time I want
sabbatical now and my book project has
absolutely nothing to do with what we're
talking about here but it drew me back
into the world of ethics in a big way
that I have not been for quite some time
and looking at that and superimposing it
with what's been going on with open
access and the stuff we've missed there
there it went and that's that's how I
can explain it that's the best I can do
Brewster and I can't resist jumping in
here now because I I now have an iphone
and I get to see what you all are saying
on Twitter and there's a comment here
that I think is is great somebody has
referenced the idea of a social contract
which I think maybe maps onto your
concept about compliance and an alliance
that you can think about the contract as
you know it the way lawyers think of it
as you must comply to the letter or you
can think about the concept of a
contract as a fair bargain between
between parties that do have interest
different interests and you you honor
the the big points but but maybe to use
some other metaphors that are being
brought up in the Twitter conversation
the the concept of selective ignorance
which was mentioned but we could also
think about this in terms of a tolerance
divide
or of a helpless abandonment somebody
else wanted to to respond to this
question or shall I throw you another
one no no I'll I'm happy to jump into
that no I think that there's a lot to be
said for that for for all those various
points it seems to me that first and
foremost on this alignment a compliance
issue and this also goes to kennys
fragmentation point I think that the the
critical factor going forward is it
means that faculty really really need to
pay a lot more attention to all of this
and they have been and I and I certainly
could understand I appreciate my dad as
a professor of comparative literature at
UCLA and he you know he now sometimes
comes to me with copyright questions and
he realizes that he assigned rights away
years ago and he's annoyed about and
just understand how that happened and I
have to try to explain to him or all
these things or explain how it is that
that actually it right here at the old
University Yael Yael holds there's a
very famous Israeli poet whoo-hoo all of
his letter or many of his letters are
here I think actually the university
bought the letters but the copyright of
course still belongs to the widow and my
dad can't understand how it is that a
researcher can come here and look at the
letters but can't you know there are
poems that are included in the letters
the the researcher can't other than you
know quotation as permitted to the
extent permitted by fair use the the
researcher can't sort of reproduce the
letters these as well you know it's if
Yale owns the copy but i have to say
well yay loans the copy but the widow
owns the copyright and so the point is
is that that we're getting into this
very very complicated world where it in
and i think that that faculty really are
going to have to learn a lot more
understand a lot more and and but
hopefully exercise a lot more control
going forward because otherwise we're
just going to continue this this
fragmentation is this going to get worse
and worse thank you here's the other
thing that I'm noticing from from the
Twitter feed the the quote that has been
picked up the most by members of this
audience and is the the meme now making
its rounds through everyone's social
networks is the quotation about
libraries needing to practice civil
disobedience and moral courage um that
that was well received so I'm not going
to lose my job APPL sabbatical but i
guess i'm not sure it needs to be civil
disobedience I mean a lot of it is is
perfectly within the framework of fair
use and so and so you know if we if we
you know fair use properly understood is
not civil disobedience it's complete
compliance with the law and on that
theme there was a specific question
posed on on Twitter that I actually want
to throw to the audience with a show of
hands and the question was you know in
the theme of civil disobedience you know
you know how much of this fear is real
how much of this you know legal risk is
is real versus imagined and the question
was who's institution has actually been
sued over some kind of alleged copyright
violation show of hands who knows that
that this has been an issue at their
institution robe left and and how many
can say that their institution has been
threatened with litigation even if it
didn't come to pass more hands they're
still a relatively small show of hands
maybe because people aren't at liberty
to say let's take your question let's
take your question and then all i'll
throw in my own and
have a final round of responses from the
panelists well thanks first of all for
such an exciting and dynamic panel the
environmental movement has this term
that they'd like to kind of throw out
when someone is engaging in anti
environmental practices that you know
nonetheless they sort of claim our in
fact for the environment it's called
green washing and I wonder if there's in
some ways among publishers particularly
in the world of academic publishing
something comparable going on because it
was interesting to see the discussions
about copyright and open access that
were coming out of the panel and there's
to me a kind of mismatch between what
academic authors understand is copyright
and the entitlements of copywriter of
open access and what those actually mean
to publishers and by that what I mean
specifically is there's a humanities and
social science publisher by the name of
sage they're kind of a mid-level
publisher and one of the things they
like Taylor & Francis allow academic
authors to do is to retain copyright in
their work provided they're willing at
the time of signing a contract you know
to design an extra provider that says
okay I actually get to keep the
copyright but that actually effectively
means nothing in practice because all of
the other aspects of the contract
assigned rights of you know not
ownership but pretty much everything
else you know to the publisher it's same
thing with open access also so you know
Taylor & Francis has this wonderful open
access policy they say we are an open
access publisher we support the spirit
of open access and yet what open access
means to them is that you have to pay
them three thousand four thousand
dollars either as an individual or as an
institution to buy back the rights to
your work so that you can actually put
the final PDF up on your website so I
wonder if there is any work coming out
of the library community or the
copyright community the open access
community that would try in a sense to
combat this kind of I don't know what to
call this greenwashing as its apply it
is library washing I guess you could
call it great question there about green
washing and whether we should be on the
lookout for something similar in this
area and then on the heels of that let
me throw out my final question as well
which is the the future of copyright and
particularly as it pertains to the task
of librarianship whose hands does it
rest in is it more in the hands of
authors
is it more in the hands of publishers or
some other group entirely I think it's
more in publishers hands I'm not saying
it should be but it's their business and
their business models and they're not
going to give up the fight easily and by
the way sage is one of the three named
plaintiffs in the Georgia State case so
you know and and and the other thing
that's funny is I say well it's
university presses and you go yet
Cambridge and Oxford not so much
university presses really I mean they
are but they're almost commercial
because they're so large but so i just
want to point that out but i think
publishers are going to be the ones that
will continue to drive this we can try
to drive it too but we are also
representatives of our institutions and
it depends on how risk-averse they are
because you know our libraries can't go
out at the North Carolina and make a
pronouncement it's going to be
University Council that's going to
control whether that can be done or not
and what the University's position will
be we can argue with them real good but
that's about it and and and i'll respond
to a couple of those points too and that
is said that yes they'll give you a
straight answer to your to your last
point but whose whose hands is this in
and i'm going to say that initially it's
really in the hands of the authors
because that that's the structure of the
law you know you know if we're talking
about status quo if i'm the author of
that work assuming it's not a
work-for-hire if i'm the author that
work I've got all the rights and I hold
all those rights until I give them away
and and I'm having these conversations
all over the country all over the world
with authors about their their
publication agreements with publishers
about their publication agreements and
and really trying to make the point that
we need to manage these works and man
these copyrights much better than we
have in the past and that means the
power is really with the rights holder
and initially that's the author make
some decisions and then I know the
institutional structures the pressure of
promotion tenure revenue publication you
know I know all that but all that's
changing and authors again you need to
not only change your agreements you not
only need to change your outlook but
you're part of that system you're part
of all those other elements and you need
to work from the inside to change that
too oh yeah there's like two parts to
that one is a completely agree that it's
that there's a lot the institution is it
is in theory the author but but but the
author part of it I think is a
generational issue I mean sort of like
the difference between my dad's
generation and my generation and then
you know certainly the newer people
coming up are much more aware I think
every generation there is a greater and
awareness and greater familiarity with
the issues and more interest in exerting
control but the flip side of it is and
this is where the institution comes in a
lot of it has to as you mentioned so
much of it is driven by the tenure
decision and and junior faculty wanting
to publish with certain publishers in
order to get tenure and so that's where
it comes you know from that has to be
accessory there's going to be the bottom
up from the author's choosing to go to
certain certain publishers but there's
on the on the other side that really has
to be this top-down from you know the
university presidents and you know that
the again people of my dad's generation
who are running these places I guess now
it's more in my generation to who you
know to say okay these are the it's okay
the junior faculty gets as much credit
for publishing and an open access
publisher as in the read or as in the
Death Star publisher that they both get
equal weight final comment from Denise
thank you I I agree that the future it's
in the hands that the control here is in
the hands of the authors i agree with
jonathan that you know the institution
has a major role and they need to chain
sort of the recognition and reward
system but it's the graduate students or
the undergraduates who will soon be the
graduate students who are going to be
accustomed to open access this is going
to be what they expect this is what
they're going to do this is where the
change is coming this is the existence
proof the publishers can Yammer Yammer
Yammer however they want from the 1990s
but those graduate students and
undergraduate students are not going to
take that and on that note we invite
everyone to take a break enjoy some
coffee and continue the conversation